sir Billy Evans
they had emerged from the political
deadlock inside to reflect on a day
which rocked this country the day
America's Democratic stability was
tested
today members of the House of
Representatives in a bipartisan way
pause in solemn recognition of the
violent attack
on the capital that occurred two years
ago on January 6 2021.
to his right the former Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi she was a Target two
years ago
[Applause]
bring her out
time has revealed that this was no
organic protest it was an organized
Insurrection driven by far-right groups
encouraged by then president Trump
from the current president citizens
medals for those who his office believes
defended democracy back then a police
officer on duty that day
Albert Schmidt a Republican election
official who refused Trump's demands to
overturn the election
[Applause]
Stephen Sund was the chief of the
capital police two years ago my most
visceral memory on January 6 and it was
a it was a tough tough dark day uh it
was 12 53 p.m
I look up when I see this crowd of
hundreds coming across Garfield Circle
and then another crowd coming across
peace Circle approaching our line of
officers right there at the walkways
the line we need backups
intelligence was a disaster we now know
that significant intelligence existed
saying people were coordinating an
attack on the capitol that didn't get
into the right hands that you didn't
know about it no but it's his
projections as well as his Reflections
which are alarming we're a very dividing
country right now and I I blame
politicians on both sides the rhetoric
the the lack of being able to just work
with your fellow politician just sets a
standard that Americans are just
mimicking they need to they need to grow
up and act like adults and in the
building behind McCarthy the dysfunction
he talks about for all to see
Division and Deadlock a chamber unable
to choose a speaker this has not
happened for well over a century
Jeffries the business of government
stalled by just a handful of
ultra-conservative Republicans enabled
by the divisive politics of Donald Trump
and now disrupting on their own McCarthy
Mark Stone Sky News in Washington